[Music]
foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
perhaps you remember the Jetsons yes
that 1960s cartoon series about a space
age family that lives in the future
they had robots and they cruised around
in flying cars
well it looks like the future has caught
up with fiction Swedish company Jetson
Arrow has built what it says as the
first commercially available personal
flying car
the company says it hopes the vehicles
will be able to replace traditional cars
in the future
the carbon fiber and aluminum vehicle
looks like a big drone can carry a 200
pound man up to 63 miles an hour but it
only has a flying time of about 20
minutes
that'll no doubt improve over time as
Battery Technology advances
so now for about a hundred thousand
dollars you can purchase your own flying
car without a pilot's license
I don't know Pastor Ross that sounds
pretty interesting but you sure wouldn't
want the the battery to die on you when
you're at about ten thousand feet that's
right that's the deck it sure would be
nice to be able to get into your drone
and fly to wherever you need to go
especially when traffic's bad that's
right you wonder what the traffic in the
air is going to be like in a few years
if that keeps moving forward but you
know the idea of flying has always been
something that's fascinated people you
look at the birds and how it can fly and
of course you flow many a time uh in
your plane and then also commercial
flying
but this there's something special about
just breaking gravity and being able to
soar in the air and of course we even
find the Bible speaking about a time
when when the redeem will fly that's
right there's not a lot of verses but
there's a few that explain we will be
able to fly like Angels do one is an
Isaiah 40 verse 31.
but those who wait upon the Lord shall
renew their strength they will Mount up
with wings like eagles they'll run and
not be weary they will walk and not
faint
and so I'm I'm looking forward to uh as
it says in the song Rock of Ages soaring
Two Worlds unknown I want to fly you
have to worry about your batteries dying
heavy there you know we have a book
that's called Heaven is it for real we
talk about heaven and it's just the
Bible says Eye Has Not Seen ear heard
neither emptied into the heart of man
the things that God is preparing for
those that love him that's right it's
hard to imagine but it's real heaven is
a real place and we'll be happy to send
you a book if you'd like to learn more
about heaven the book is called Heaven
is it for real the number to call for
that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for offer
number 189 or ask for the book by name
Heaven is it for real you can also dial
pound 250 on your smartphone and just
say Bible answers live and ask for the
book Heaven is it for real we'll be
happy to send it to you anyone in the
U.S and Canada if you're outside of
North America you can just go to the
website
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
read the book right there online or
pastor we always want to greet those who
are joining us we have folks listening
not only on the radio and on satellite
radio but we have people joining us who
are on social media watching on YouTube
also on Amazing Facts TV and some of the
other television networks that partner
with us in this so we want to greet all
of you if you have a Bible question the
phone line here at the studio is
800-463-7297 that's 800 God says
463-7297 that'll bring you here into the
studio with your Bible question or
Pastor like before we go to the phone
lines let's start with the word of
prayer all right dear father we thank
you for your word we thank you for the
opportunity to be able to study and
tonight we ask the Holy Spirit to be
with us here in the studio be with those
who are listening and watching wherever
they might be lead us into a clearer
understanding of the Bible in Jesus name
amen amen I first call it today we've
got Ellie listening in Texas Ellie
welcome to the program
hi can you hear me we do thanks for
calling
awesome thank you for answering
hope you're doing well I have a question
today in regards to First Corinthians
chapter 11 verse
10 where it says
for this cause the woman to have power
over her head because of the angels and
my main question was on the explanation
because of the Angels what what does
that exactly mean
yeah well this is a very interesting
passage where it talks about uh in part
the relationship between men and women
and a woman's hair
especially like praying in public and so
Paul is addressing issues for the first
the first letter to the Corinthians of
propriety and some of what we believe is
related to custom but it was understood
that as a sign of humility God has given
women hair as a covering and if they
pray in public they should cover their
hair because the hair is their Glory as
a sign of their humility if you look in
the book of Isaiah chapter 6 it says
that the Angels cover their faces in
their feet in the presence of God and so
it says the Angels you know are
beholding when you address God and as a
sign of humility that women should cover
their heads the big question among
theologians is was this a Commandment
that is universal for Christians through
ages because it's mentioned once in the
Bible and the Bible says in the mouth of
two or three Witnesses we should
establish our doctrines not one verse
and it's not mentioned anywhere else so
or was it a custom
and later on and maybe Pastor also
helped me find what verse is it where he
says that we have 16 verse 16. it says
but if anyone seems to be contentious we
have no such custom nor the Churches of
God so many are wondering is this was
this a custom
seems as though the the principle there
is reverence and respect when you enter
the house of God and you're involved in
worship you know I said we've traveled
to different places around the world and
it's very interesting when you go to
these different cultures they have
different signs of reverence and respect
we're in India one of the largest
Christian churches you're invited to
speak there and uh it was very
interesting for us of their sign of
reverence and respect is to remove their
shoes when they enter into the church
and so you go to this church that had
thousands of members and neatly out
front they have little boxes and
everybody puts their sandals in their
box and then they go into the church so
that was a sign of reverence in our
culture probably if you're a man and you
walk into a church you're wearing a hat
it's appropriate to remove the hat so
there are certain Customs Even in our
society that show reverence yeah and for
people have seen the Jews praying in the
Wailing Wall for them the men always
cover their heads when they approach and
you know we've been together they're at
the Western Wall and when you go up
they'll tell you if you have a baseball
cap you're okay but if not they'll hand
you cardboard yamaga something they said
do not approach this holy place without
covering your head so this was a custom
We Believe of reverence that Paul is
addressing I hope that helps a little
bit Ellie and we appreciate your
patience
next color that we have is UNIF
listening in Nevada junith welcome to
the program
hello good evening Pastor uh dog and
Pastor Ross can you hear me yes
yes okay
um my question is
um wasn't the uh the decision of Sarah
for Abram to have a kid with Hager it
was not God's will but then if it was
not good it will could this be a major
reason why the second coming of Jesus is
slanted up because it has a lot of
compromise in this decision
thank you for answering yes okay well
thank you Jonas the the the decision of
Abraham
to uh at Sarah's suggestion to use Hagar
as sort of a surrogate wife to have a
baby she basically was functioning as a
concubine back in those days uh that was
definitely not in God's will ultimately
God told Abraham when Sarah said send
her away God said yes send her away
basically it was a divorce as far as we
know he never saw Hagar again and it
brought all kinds of strife into the
family and through history The
Descendants that ended up going into you
know Muhammad and the Muslims the Arab
world and the children of Abraham there
has been so much Strife between the
Nations that came out of that decision
now your question has that postponed the
coming of the Lord I don't know I don't
know that I could speculate about that
it is interesting that the two largest
religions in the world today
Christianity and Islam
spring out of that decision or you can
see the fork you should say because of
that decision so um
yeah that was not God's will clearly God
said I will give you a son through Sarah
your wife
and multiple marriages is not God's plan
and we recognize that when God said to
Abraham take your son your only son whom
thou lovest right he's talking about
Isaac so you know you think about that
Pastor Doug both of these large
religious movements you've got
Christianity or Judaism and you've got
Islam of course Christianity came out of
Judaism they all heart back to Abraham
and a lot has to do with that decision
whether or not to be faithful to God to
trust in God little did he realize what
would come of that decision yeah it goes
to show how one mistake like that has
ramifications just like the mistake of
Adam and Eve look what's going on in the
world the mistake of Abraham has had
long lasting as you say ramifications
thank you appreciate your questions
Judith we've got Gary listening in
Illinois Gary welcome to Bible answers
live
angel in Revelation 9 14 and then again
in Revelation 16 12 it says when the
Euphrates River dries up more demonic
angels will be released and kill one
third of the population and their power
is fire smoke and brimstone so is that
power is are they describing uh hell is
are those angels going to release hell
on Earth
okay well when you read about four
Angels who are prepared
for an hour a day a month and a year
you also see in Revelation chapter seven
is it seven where it says there are four
Angels holding back the Four Winds of
strife
uh it doesn't say they're demonic people
are assuming that so the angels that are
holding back the Winds of strife and
then you read here in this chapter talks
about angels again Four Angels four
really represents in the Bible this is
universal God Jesus said he'll send his
angels to the four corners of the earth
to gather together the elect so what is
going to happen here both in Revelation
chapter 7 and chapter
9 is talking about something Universal
when you look at the euphriguez river
you need to know some Bible History that
isn't specifically in the Bible there
are prophecies that allude to it
before the children of Israel were freed
from Babylon to go back to the promised
land the Euphrates dried up the reason
it dried up is because Cyrus The General
and wanting to conquer Babylon the river
Euphrates ran under the walls of ancient
Babylon which was a huge City
and he knew that if he could divert the
river they they dug a ditch big ditch he
had an army do it they diverted the
water from the Euphrates into a dry lake
bed and the water level going under the
walls of Babylon dropped it dried up the
Persians marched under the walls they
sent a little contingent under they
opened up the inner gates and left the
rest of the Army in
and um
so for the Jew the drying up the
Euphrates is a Harbinger that they would
soon be going back to the promised land
so when it tells us in this sixth plague
that you read about in The Seven Last
plagues
it at least has a spiritual application
there
that the power of the Beast Babylon is
going to dry up
and you find a lot about Babylon in
chapter 17 of Revelation now whether
there is a literal application
makes you wonder sometimes because you
know in Revelation it talks about
before the Lord comes the sun will be
dark and the Moon Turns The Blood the
stars fall from Heaven Powers Heaven are
shaken or Heavens roll back is a scroll
those things have happened historically
sort of as wake up signs
but they're going to happen literally in
quick succession just before the second
coming
and so I think maybe God is using the
fact the Euphrates by the way the
Euphrates is not totally dried up it's
just gone down and they're predicting
it's going to dry up I wonder sometimes
if the Lord is using that to at least
get people's attention but I wouldn't
wait for four demons to come out of a
cave I've heard people say there's some
demons coming out of a cave by the
Euphrates River doesn't say anywhere
these are demons
and while there's two drying up the
Riverview afraid you alluded to it
you've got the sixth trumpet right the
Four Angels released from the Riverview
Euphrates and then you have the drying
up the rephrase which is one of the
plagues right in Revelation chapter 9
but it talks about the sixth trumpet and
the four angels that are bound in the
great review Euphrates a number of
theologians many of them especially the
early Protestant reformers identified
that as the expansion of Islam under the
Turks or the ottomani that was a
judgment for the Judgment that came upon
the Christian State Christianity that's
right and they've identified the four
main tribal groups that formed the
Ottoman Empire and their location in
Baghdad another one in Aleppo
Iconium Damascus so these are sort of
the Capital Areas connected with Europe
Euphrates but that's where these tribes
came from that formed the Ottoman Empire
as a judgment under the Sixth trumpet
but then you have the drying up the
river Euphrates which is under the
plagues as well yeah in Revelation 16.
well thank you appreciate that uh Gary
and don't have a book we can offer on
that but
somebody we could write yeah it would be
interesting Jerry listening in Texas
Jerry walked to the program
hey pastors I want to get your guys tank
on this uh one text in Genesis Genesis 6
21 and referring to the beasts of prey
when they came on the art where of
course we know that God can sustain like
he sustained Moses on the on the Mount
Sinai for 40 days
but were the lions and tigers
vegetarians on the ark I guess they
would have to be were they vegetarians
before okay good question
well so yeah the animals that were on
the Ark of course he took uh two of the
clean animals and and uh the unclean I'm
sorry the clean animals were taken by
sevens the unclean animals were taken by
twos so what did the carnivorous animals
eat well it says that Noah was told to
bring food for them so there was extra
food
um you know ostensibly he didn't read
like live animals for the Lions to eat
the other thing is they've shown is that
when animals are taken on a boat they go
into a type of hibernation when boats
are rocking they sort of they eat very
less they're not mobile and they
probably were not eating a lot on the
boat
um but yeah Noah was told to bring food
for him so he brought something the
Lions could eat
and of course Lions can live probably
not their preference but they can't live
in a vegetarian diet yeah it's a model
modern examples of lions that just for
some reason little take is what I'm
thinking of a lion that just refused to
eat meat and he lived very well on she
she lived very well on a diet of grains
and eggs and yeah amazing I agree to a
full-grown lion okay thank you Jerry
we've got Sam listening in Canada Sam
welcome to the program
hi thanks for calling and your question
uh yes uh it is in um I have a question
related to
um how do they know the Bible is
inspired
um I've I'm studying right now in
University and we learn about like the
different flood myths around around the
world and it's just how similar it is to
the Bible's um
Noah's flood yeah I'm glad you asked uh
actually the different myths that you
find around the world regarding the
flood like the Babylonians have the Epic
of Gilgamesh the Hawaiians have a
similar Legend
those myths grew out of the true
incident that Moses records Moses gives
us the accurate account the other epics
or stories whether it's the Greek myth
of a worldwide flood you've got the
story in Greek mythology about this
powerful race that lived in this land
called Atlantis
and because of their wickedness the
island was swallowed up well it's the
flood it's this powerful race that lived
that because of the wickedness they were
destroyed
uh even Pandora's Box the idea of this
woman opened the box that was full of
evil she wasn't supposed to open well it
was Eve eating the forbidden fruit over
time some of these these true stories
they get changed as they're passed along
and you develop these different myths
but I think that's evidence the Bible is
true in the Bible you're getting the
truth about what really happened these
other civilizations uh you know the Jews
were very careful of writing these
things down
and one reason God told Moses to write
it down is because over time when they
used to Sherry share their history
orally there was a risk that things were
going to be changed so Moses was
inspired to write down the accurate
account of what happened
and it has stood the test of time you
know we have a book it's called the
ultimate resource and it's all about the
Bible and pass it I just mentioned one
or two but there are many proofs in the
Bible itself of its divine origin that
the Bible is inspired you've got
prophecy you've got history or
archeology so the little book will give
you more information it's called
ultimate resource and it's all about the
Bible to receive that call
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
it's called ultimate resource you can
also dial pound 250 say Bible answers
live and ask for the book ultimate
resource next caller that we have is Lee
listening in Texas Lee welcome to the
program
thank you
are you there
Lee you may have hit your mute button or
something we just lost you
are you there yeah we hear you now go
ahead
yes sir my question is who is Satan in
the Book of Revelation that does false
Miracles I mean I know who the
Antichrist is and the man of sin is that
who is supposed to be Satan
okay well uh in Revelation chapter 12
for instance it talks about him as the
dragon it says that Dragon of old the
devil Satan so it uses four different
titles there that we can't confuse the
serpent
Satan Dragon
um devil
and that's I think it mentions that
twice in the Revelation 12. no it does
twice in Revelation and so you might be
wondering when it talks about the Beast
the dragon and the false prophet
and you know there you've got a dragon
certainly the devil it tells us that
that old serpent the dragon the devil
and that goes back to the Garden of Eden
when the devil Lucifer he basically used
the medium of a serpent to deceive Adam
and Eve now because the Bible does tell
us that before Jesus comes there's going
to be many false christs and false
prophets and the Bible also says don't
be surprised because the Devil Himself
can be transformed into an angel of
Light so it wouldn't surprise us if the
devil tries to impersonate the second
coming of Jesus now we know according to
the Bible that when Jesus comes the
second time he's not going to be walking
on the earth the righteous are caught up
to meet him in the air so if somebody
appears even if they do perform Miracles
and they're walking around in the earth
that's a false Christ that's a false
Christ so the Bible does give us these
these guidelines these pointers next
color that we have is Angela and
Angelina sorry from Oregon Angelina
welcome to the program
thank you thank you and bless us God
bless you both
thank you for calling your question
um my question is
um I was looking uh when Jesus called
the disciples
but uh I heard somebody said
that Jesus didn't call Judas Iscariot to
be his his disciple or his oh like one
of the Apostles that somebody
took him to Jesus and recommended him to
Jesus because he was good for for the
group and uh other comment was that
Judas invite himself to be one of Jesus
disciples
and I need to find out where in the
gospel yeah the Judas didn't
was not called by Jesus well it says in
Matthew 8 19 that there was a certain
scribe that said to him teacher I will
follow you wherever you go now with most
of the Apostles Christ said follow me
and they left their Nets and they
followed him he said Matthew follow me
and he followed him he asked the rich
and ruler follow me and he didn't follow
and here you've got a scribe that says
sir I will follow you wherever you go
and many believe this was Judas because
this person this scribe was hoping for
some Earthly gain and Jesus answers and
says the foxes have their dens and the
birds of the air have their nest but the
son of man has nowhere to lay your head
in other words if you're following me
because you think you're going to get
ahead in the world
don't follow me and you know and it's
not it it's not specifically in the
scriptures but some understand that the
disciples were so impressed with the
education and the Brilliance Of The
Scribe by the name of Judas they
recommended him to Jesus and Jesus
allowed him in now there is a place in
the Bible where Jesus says have I not
chosen you twelve and one of you is a
devil
so Christ did ultimately lay hands on
Judas like he did the others and say
okay you're recommending them to me I'm
going to go ahead and treat him like an
apostle but he kind of put himself
forward as opposed to being called if we
assume that the Scribe is Judas and we
also have some other references to where
Judas actually held the money back so we
know yeah he was the treasurer of the
group yeah so holding a position of
influence good question thank you next
caller that we have is Taylor listening
in South Dakota Taylor welcome to the
program
hello pastors uh my question is on
Joshua
21 verse 44 where it says that the Lord
delivered all their enemies into their
hand of them being uh Israelites but in
another passage in chapter 15 verse 63
it says that after the jebusites uh the
children of Judah could not drive them
out and there's a couple other instances
in chapters 16 and 17. so I guess I'm
wondering why it says that he delivered
all their enemies when there's a few
instances where they didn't
yeah I think that it's just an
understanding of the phraseology
everybody that Joshua went against in
battle God delivered them
there's only one example where Joshua's
Army lost the battle and he came back
and then wanted the you know he won the
war against AI the initial battle
against A.I they were defeated God
humbled them they prayed and then they
went back they defeated AI they defeated
all the kings of the amorites everyone
they fought against
that but they made the mistake of once
they basically dominated the land they
got comfortable they inhabited the
cities they driven most of them out
um but they began to tolerate some of
them even by the time of King David
David is still trying to get the
jebusites out of Jerusalem so they
seemed to be some mopping up operations
you might say that needed to occur by
the various tribes once they occupied
the land some tribes were more diligent
in doing that others kind of just
settled in and they didn't finish the
work yeah I figured once the other
tribes once the other nations are paying
taxes and they're not bothering us
anymore we're tired of War we want to
start farming and the problem was by
allowing those uh Pagan Nations to live
among them their children began to
intermarry
and that's what happened with Samson and
others and God said this is what's going
to happen they're going to be thorns in
your sides and I think he said sand in
your eyes and and it became a real curse
because they didn't completely drive
them out as they were supposed to
but everyone they in the days of Joshua
everyone they fought against in battle
was delivered to them
okay next quality that we have is Caleb
listening in New York Caleb welcome to
the program
hello pastors how are you guys doing
today doing great thank you for calling
yeah so
it's about Romans 9. verses 11 11 to 13.
I'm just confused about it because
um it makes me a little bit nervous
because I just want to know
um if you saw ever given and how does
that apply to us how do we know we get
we're forgiven did Esau know he was
hated like
even be in heaven I mean he forgive his
brother
I'm just a little bit confused about
from um Romans 9 to 11. yeah from 11 to
13.
yeah and I'll read this for friends it
says in Romans chapter 9 verse 11 for
the children not yet being born nor
having done any good or evil that the
purpose of God according to election
might stand not of works but according
to him who calls it was said to her the
older Shall Serve the younger as it is
written Jacob I've loved but Esau I've
hated now that is a big question so you
hear the music friends if you want to
hear the answer gotta stay with us we're
coming back after the break and we'll
answer that
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
Can't Get Enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at
aftv.org at
aftv.org you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
hi friends I think everybody knows that
there is a Health crisis in the country
it used to be years ago when people
worked on farms and got a lot more
physical activity that they'd eventually
get old they'd get sick and they'd die
but today what happens is people get
sick and spend 30 years dying because of
their poor living practices well amazing
facts is going to be bringing a program
to you that's going to teach you how you
can have a longer stronger more abundant
Optimum life and it's called The Amazing
Facts Health Summit it'll be at the
hilltop Church in Granite Bay February
24 and 25 you can also watch on Amazing
Facts television you can see it on
YouTube on our Facebook Channel but we'd
love to have you come in person we're
going to have some great speakers there
and it will change your life in fact I'm
feeling better already I feel more
healthy how about you guys
[Music]
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating Zoo
creation of the world to the last day of
events of Revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major Bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the Bible and draw closer to God's word
go deeper visit biblehistory.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you have a Bible
question just give us a call the number
is 800 God says we are also broadcasting
on the amazing facts Facebook page the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page amazing
fact YouTube page
amazing facts television and uh program
airs a number of other stations also and
uh Reit broadcast so you may want to
participate in calling your Bible
question and it'll be a blessing to
others as well my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross and just before the
breakpass today we were talking with
Caleb and he had a question about Romans
chapter 9 where it says Jacob I have
loved Esau I have hated almost gives the
idea that they were predestinated even
before their birth
yeah it's this is referring to not uh
Jacob individually necessarily Esau as
an individual could end up being saved
not every Edomite the descendants of
Esau were called not every
Edomite is lost and not every Israelite
is saved
in every individual based on their lives
the Esau did make a big mistake and he
sold his Birthright for a pot of beans
well that doesn't mean he couldn't have
repented later and turned to the Lord
and been saved so this is not dealing
with that but the nation of the
generally turned away from God and
turned to paganism
and they are called Esau the nation of
Jacobs was called Israel and so when and
so when it says I've Loved Jacob and
I've hated Esau it's not talking about
the individuals I've just decided I'm
going to hate this one I love this one
it's saying because God knew in advance
what they were going to do he could
foretell
um which one was going to serve the
other and it was also God just choosing
I mean the Bible says God didn't choose
Israel because they were more numerous
or better than the other nations he
chose Israel and was through Israel that
the Messiah was to come so in that sense
the nation was chosen by God nothing
about individuals right talking about
the nation Israel was chosen it was set
apart to prepare the way for the first
coming of Jesus yeah and you can't
really understand Romans chapter 9
unless you know what is Paul quoting
Paul is quoting the Old Testament he's
quoting Malachi chapter 1 verse 2. it
says I have loved you says the Lord yet
you say in what way have you loved us
was not Esau Jacob's brother says the
Lord yet I loved but Jacob of love and
Esau I've hated and I laid waste his
mountains and his Heritage for the
jackals of the Wilderness it's talking
about a judgment that fell on the
descendants of Esau not so much the
individuals but their Nation you know I
think we have some good evidence pass
today that ESO actually if you read
about the death of Isaac and you have
Jacob and Esau actually coming together
to bury their father so it appears as
though there was reconciliation at least
between the two of them ESO could very
well at the end of his life have
returned to the god of his father could
have been a worship of the true God but
again we're not talking about
individuals here we're talking about the
Nations right that's represented next
caller that we have is Bradley listening
in Missouri Bradley welcome to the
program
good evening pastors thank you for
taking my call
my question tonight is uh on Revelation
14 verse 10 and 11 and
um I see a lot of verses uh in the in
the Bible that teach against Eternal
Hellfire but I'm actually confused with
the phrase in Revelation 14 where it
says the ones that take the mark have no
rest day nor night
um so my question is if the wicked after
being destroyed or sleeping
um I guess what does it mean when it
says they are not resting day nor night
yeah well for one thing one of the big
battles in the last days is uh whether
or not we're going to be serving God or
serving the Pharaoh you remember what
the Pharaoh said to Moses
they said let my people go that they
might worship God and Pharaoh said I'm
not going to let them you're not working
hard enough don't give them any straw
anymore that they may not think about
um
worshiping God
and mo a pharaoh said to Moses you're
causing the people to shabbat
Pharaoh said you're causing them to rest
those that worship the Beast have no
rest Jesus said come unto me I will give
you rest so the and in Hebrews it says
they will enter into my rest the rest
here isn't talking about like you know
not perspiring because you're digging a
ditch it's talking about they have no
peace No Rest who worship the Beast
there's also judgment that's portrayed
In this passage so on the one hand
there's rest a lack of rest now for the
unbeliever but there is a day of
judgment the Bible is quite clear and in
that day of judgment the Bible says
everyone shall be rewarded according to
his Works Revelation chapter 20 talks
about the Lake of Fire
And if every person needs to be rewarded
according to their works not everyone's
going to suffer the same in other words
some will die almost instantaneously
others might suffer a little longer the
devil probably will suffer the longest
and it appears at least a day and a
night he will suffer it won't be Eternal
there won't be any you know he will
ultimately be consumed as the Bible says
that the wick could become ashes and the
devil's turn to ashes on the Earth but
there are penalties there are judgments
that will come on the wicked yep and
when it says just to add to that the
smoke of the of their torment it sends
up forever and ever and they have no
rest today those who worship the image
when it says the smoke of their
tormented sense forever it's not saying
that they're going to be tormented
forever but the consequence of that
Judgment of that fire is forever and
ever those are destroyed in the Hell
Fire at the end of the 1000 Years there
is no resurrection that comes out of
that they are eternally lost and so the
consequences of the judgment is forever
and ever so the smokes forever not the
fire and that's just an idiomatic
expression that we find there in the
Book of Revelation yes all right next
one on that we have is Hector listening
from Florida Hector welcome to the
program
have a good evening everybody evening
my question
through two investors that I have in
front of me one taken from John 13 verse
2 to 3.
he's talking about my father's house of
many mentions
and uh we got Isaiah 65
verse 21 in 22.
a Jesus way as Jesus is preparing house
and his father house have many mentions
for us
and he he went there to prepare a place
while Isaiah Isaiah page 65 we have to
build houses and inhabit them yeah and
the short plants Vineyards and eat the
fruits of them yeah there's 22
constructed what they say and they
should not build and another it might be
what can you explain about this yeah
good question well first of all you're
gonna have more than one house
uh Jesus says that he's preparing a
place in the New Jerusalem that's what
comes down from God out of heaven and
then we will go forth you read in
Malachi chapter 4. we're going to go
forth from the New Jerusalem and it says
we will you know God's going to create a
new heavens and a new Earth the whole
planet is going to be available for
inhabiting the Garden of Eden that was
created and planted by God Before the
Flood we assume that God took the garden
up the tree of life it's all in the New
Jerusalem it's the Garden of Eden
Central Park of the New Jerusalem
but we're not all just going to live in
the city with this beautiful world God's
created they're going to go forth from
the New Jerusalem and we will have our
own Country Estates and we're going to
build houses on them and we will plant
Vineyards see God made Adam and Eve to
to be horticulturists to plant and to
build and to develop God made man to
create and do stuff we're not going to
just sit there on clouds and play Harps
in the New Jerusalem
so basically Pastor Doug you're saying
everyone will have two houses you've got
your city house You've Got Your Country
House you've got a house a mansion in
the Ninja Jerusalem and then you have a
place that you get to design and build
and you can buy whatever you want for
your house and put it on your father's
account that's right you'll cover it all
right thank you Hector next call is Don
from Oklahoma Don welcome to the program
all right yeah
um my question is uh
in Matthew 7 verse 22
uh those will come to Jesus and say Lord
Lord have we not prophesied in your name
and done uh cast out devils in your name
and so on and if of course his response
is uh I never knew you
um so my question is uh
if they didn't know him how are they
performing these uh miracles in his name
well you could ask the question is it
possible for a person
who isn't converted
to be casting out devils
um you have the example of the bible
where jesus I'm sorry Judas followed
Jesus
and Jesus sent out the 12 apostles and
they came back and said even the demons
are subject unto us
and the the apostles were really
confused one day you read this in Mark
chapter nine they could not cast out a
devil and they said what's the problem
we usually cast them out we couldn't
cast this one out
but Judas was in that group and he was
evidently casting out devils and you
know there's something about the power
of the the word and the power of the
Lord sometimes God can even speak
through a donkey if he wants to so you
can have someone they're not totally
converted they can preach and the power
of the word can still convert people and
the Devils can be cast out of that
person's life because the power is in
the word and the person themselves
may not even be converted that's right
past it like I mean you look at people
in the Bible you have soul King Saul who
was filled with the spirit at the
beginning even prophesied and yet we
find him at the end of his life totally
turning against God so God can use
people and the power is in the word
just because somebody does a miracle it
doesn't always mean that they're always
going to be doing what's right
so these are people that they were going
through the religious motions even
seeing some fruit
but they weren't surrendered
thanks good question we got Isaac
listening from New York
Isaac welcome to the program
yeah yes
[Music]
um
faster Bachelor
my name is I'm 14 years old and I will
and I
and I would like to know if
um
if there would be any Electronics in
heaven or lamps or anything like that
thank you all right yeah good question
well you can read in Revelation it says
that in the New Jerusalem there's no
need of the Sun
for the Lord God he lights the city
so the whole city is illuminated with a
light that comes from God's presence
you know God is brighter than the sun
Jesus is referred to as the son of
righteousness so I don't think we're
going to need a nuclear power plant to
give us electricity in the new Earth the
glory of God is going to light things
now does that mean that as time goes by
there'll be no science where we're going
to be using any kind of invention or
power maybe even electric power I don't
know you know God created all these
interesting physics and things and and
you know we might have some creative
uses for those in the new Earth or even
on other worlds so it's hard to say
um I don't picture we're going to have
electronic devices like we do now
but there may be
some use of electricity at some point in
the future I don't know and if you think
about it like you say past it like
Electronics is really just an
outcropping of of studying the natural
laws of nature and figuring out how to
harness those powers
in the universe to come and the earth
made new I'm sure there's going to be
people interested in trying to figure
out why things work the way they work
they'll still be signs they'll still be
Discovery they'll still be learning
I don't know if you'll need to create
you know
the network like uh what the web World
Wide Web we don't do that in heaven the
cosmic web that's right but it is
interesting we'll be learning the Bible
says eyes not seen ear heard neither
entered into the heart of man the things
that God is preparing for those that
love him thanks for your call we've got
Aaron listening New York Aaron you're on
the air
creating pastors good evening I'd like
to know the meaning of John chapter 11
verse 16.
okay three verses before it
um Jesus was explaining to his disciples
that Lazarus was dead
yeah the University team Thomas did
something that doesn't make make sense
to me can you explain it yeah well Jesus
is in he's up in the northern part of
the country around Galilee he's around
the Sea of Galilee and Jesus was born in
Nazareth which was Central Israel up in
the north
the headquarters was around Jerusalem
the religious leaders down there and the
priests they wanted Jesus dead
because the crowds were following him
Jesus had called them hypocrites and
when Jesus said I'm going back to
Bethany which is in southern Israel
right Bethany's not far from Jerusalem
Thomas he was sometimes a little bit
negative he said well we love him let's
go and we'll die with him he's going to
get killed down there but we'll go die
with him and so that's why he's saying
that because Jesus in order to resurrect
Lazarus he had to go back down to where
the hotbed of his enemies were
does that make sense
yes thanks okay thank you so much Aaron
appreciate your call and your question
next Call of the behalf is Jim listening
in Indiana Jen walk walk with the
program
yes thank you
talk to you both again
I was wondering in Revelation 16 and 17
but in 17 it says the 10 horse horns in
verse 16. the ten horns which South saw
us upon abuse these shall hate the
horror and shall make her desolate and
naked and she'll eat her flesh and burn
her with fire now is does
that they're coincide
with 15 or 16 at 21. yeah so men
uh were you talking about does
Revelation 17 where it talks about the
ten horns does that coincide with
Revelation 16
I'm not sure what you're yeah you know
when it yeah when it talks about uh and
their fellow opponent men a great hail
Out of Heaven
and every stone about the weight of a
Talon
and Men blaspheme
is
does the city get burnt by Jesus when he
comes or
yeah the in Revelation 16 you've got in
the last playing it talks about this
great hail that falls upon men and this
is the seventh plague it's all
synonymous with the second coming of
Jesus the last plague is the Lord comes
and you know there's a great earthquake
and a great hail plague
then you read in chapter 17 and keep in
mind Revelation often backs up and gives
more detail you can read in chapter 17
about the fall of Babylon and all these
plagues that seem to fall on Babylon but
the ten horns specifically are the ten
divisions
of the Roman Empire that had grown into
the you know the nations of Europe that
ended up becoming the economic
Powerhouse of the world
um and uh that where the the seed of the
Beast is
so you almost need to better understand
the ten horns you need to read our
lesson on who is the Antichrist that's
right it's just to add to that a little
bit when it talks about the ten horns it
says they Ten Kings a king represents a
kingdom so they appear as according to
Revelation 17 that there is a coalition
of Kingdoms supporting the beast power
described as Babylon in Revelation 17
but when they realize that they've been
deceived this is just before the second
coming of Christ they actually turn
against this power
so those Powers those political powers
that once supported this political
religious power ends up turning against
it and then of course you have the hail
you have the second coming of Christ so
it's right near the end the the parallel
of that is the drying up of the review
Euphrates where the support that came to
symbolic Babylon is withdrawn right
those Powers withdraw their support
okay we have Andre listening Colorado
Andre welcome to the program
oh yes thank you Pastor Jordan hear me
yes thank you for calling
yes um so my question is this one has
been confusing me for quite some some
years actually and it's in the topic of
um divorce and remarriage and uh my
question is in regards to
in the situation of a divorce where
adultery took place
and can the person who's in the wrong
um
be remarried after that
um after is there a time of you know
repentance that can take place and then
that person can get remarried and the
confusion is
um is that person not supposed to be
married for the rest of their lives or
can they be remarried eventually with
true repentance
to end of course with
um for example David and Bathsheba
wasn't he married and then he committed
adultery and then he did what he did
with the Sheba but he eventually married
her yeah so can you please explain that
please yes well what you're saying is
true uh David
oh basically he killed bathsheba's
husband
he did it at the hands of other soldiers
and then he took her to be his wife and
Nathan the prophet confronted him and
said because of what you've done
the sword will never depart from your
house
and you will because you did this thing
you will lose four of your sons
which ended up happening he lost the
baby lost Absalom lost out of Niger and
lost amnon
and so you can say yeah God did forgive
David and Bathsheba ended up becoming
his wife and God knows you can't you
know unscramble scrambled eggs I guess
God can do anything he can do that too
but you know typically once you get into
these divorce and remarriage things he
God sort of meets us where we're at when
Jesus met the woman at the well of
course she was a pagan and didn't know
any better she'd had five husbands and
was living with a man she's not married
to well he still revealed he was the
Messiah and we believe he saved her
because she goes out right away telling
everyone else
so but biblically there you know there's
no grounds for divorce and remarriage
unless the other partner has committed
adultery and Jesus said otherwise as
soon as you start making loopholes
everybody starts trying to make the
loopholes bigger marriage is it's
interesting Pastor Ross and I just came
from a marriage that's right very sacred
Covenant if you're watching our
television broadcast you see we're
dressed up a little more than usual
because we walked over from the marriage
here it's a sacred Covenant it's
supposed to be till death do you part
now when there is divorce and sometimes
people get divorced and remarried and
they don't have biblical grounds are we
saying that's the unpartum pardonable
sin no the Bible says something else is
the unpardonable sin
but I recommend you talk to a pastor
sometimes there's a lot of
more intimate details connected with
divorce and grounds for divorce then you
don't want radio pastors giving you life
advice on that you probably get someone
local
you know we do have a book pass that I
think that gives some good biblical
principles that's called marriage
divorce and remarriage and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks it's
800-835-6747 just ask the book it's
called marriage divorce and remarriage
I'll be happy to send it to you if in
Canada or the U.S if you're outside of
North America just go to the website
amazingfacts.org we've got uh Jeffrey
listening in Texas Jeffrey welcome to
the program
hey Pastor Ross
hi you on the air
hey hey I had a question uh coming out
of First Corinthians 14 and 2 where it
talks about the unknown tongue I wanted
to get you guys as a interpretation on
that on that word on unknown tongue
sorry yeah
yeah so in First Corinthians chapter 14
Paul goes into a length uh explaining
um about tongues now the word tongue
simply means language every time here in
First Corinthians where you read the
word tongue just insert the word
language
when they were speaking in their
services in the Corinthian churches they
had slaves from all over the Roman
Empire they spoke many languages their
services were becoming confusing people
were praying in public and languages no
one else understood Paul said if you're
going to pray in a tongue and when he
says unknown tongue he means unknown to
the majority there if you're praying in
a tongue that is unknown to the others
there you should have an interpreter
Paul says if not
pray to yourself
and you can read for instance in verse
7. he says even things without life
whether a flute or harp when they make a
sound unless they make a distinction in
the sounds how will it be known what is
piped or played you know when you play
music if you give it to a child they
just start playing gibberish on the
piano you don't know what the song is
there needs to be order and distinction
for you to recognize the song he said so
it is and he goes on and says if the
trumpet makes an uncertain sound who can
prepare for the battle trumpets used to
give very specific sounds
he said in the same way
there are many languages in the world
and none of them is without significance
therefore if I don't know the meaning of
the language and I'm in verse 11 now
I'll be a foreigner to him who speaks
and he will be a foreigner to me
Pastor Ross and I just came back from
Australia and they told me I had an
accent there well I never had an accent
before yeah but since I picked one up
when I got there
so uh you know we he's basically saying
speak in the languages now and you read
in verse 13 therefore let him who speaks
in a tongue pray that he might interpret
for if I pray in a tongue my spirit
prays but my understanding is unfruitful
meaning people listening it's they don't
understand what I'm saying my praying is
unfruitful to them
so the summary of it is whether you're
preaching or praying in public do it in
a language the people listening
understand or have an interpreter a
translator or don't speak
now we have a book on this and I really
hope you'll request this it's uh called
understanding tongues it's a book that
deals specifically with the subject of
tongues I know in a lot of churches
people kind of break out speaking in
tongues and it sounds like the Babylon
or gibberish and folks are wondering
what are they saying it's about the
Heavenly prayer language but there's no
example of Jesus doing this or Paul
the only time they spoke in tongues was
in Acts chapter 2 acts 10 and Acts 19
and there are several language groups
present purpose for a tongue is to
communicate thought
and
the idea of us just babbling in a
language we don't even understand is not
biblical
so if you want to find out what the
bible really says on this and it's a
pretty compelling book it's not a big
book just ask for the book understanding
tongues now listening friends we're
gonna be taking off in just a minute as
you know if you've been listening for a
while this program goes all across the
country in other parts of the world and
we kind of sign off in two stages
because some are listening via satellite
which is on a different schedule from
the land base stations so in a moment
we're going to say farewell to those who
are listening by satellite and then
we're gonna
come back and we're going to answer some
rapid fire Bible questions and two
things Pastor Ross one is how does a
person get the book unknown tongues and
the other is how do they send in their
questions okay to get the book just call
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line ask for the book it's called
understanding tongues so if happy to
send it to you if Canada or in North
America and if you'd like to email us
your Bible question and we'll include it
in our program just simply send an email
to
balquestions
amazingfacts.org BL questions at
amazingfacts.org and we'll be back in
just a few moments with some email
questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back for our email
questions all the texting questions that
are coming from Pastor Doug we have
several good ones this evening question
number one are the seven last plagues
literal or figurative
well both we believe that they're real
because you read in Revelation
um the when it talks in chapter 15 16
about the seven last plagues many of
them are similar to the plagues that
fell on Ancient Egypt which were very
real there were ten plagues that fell on
Egypt as a Prelude to their deliverance
and the journey to the promised land the
children of Israel were protected from
the last seven of those ten plagues so
in Revelation when it says there are
seven plagues God protects us through
those seven last plagues but they are
very real plagues that Prelude our
deliverance from this world and
beginning a journey to God's Promised
Land
now there may be some spiritual
applications to some of the plagues like
the darkness on the seed of the Beast
probably literal Darkness but it means
they're also living in darkness
all right next question that we have it
says when Jesus says he baptizes with
fire what does it mean
the Holy Spirit
because John the Baptist says that he
that comes after you will baptize you in
fire in the spirit he makes it clear
what that and then you look in Acts
chapter 2 when the Holy Spirit fell on
the apostles it says it came like
tongues of Fire
uh the children of Israel when they came
out of Egypt they went through the Red
Sea baptized in water and then they were
baptized in a pillar of fire that God
used to protect them we need both
baptisms
did Jesus die on Wednesday if the Bible
says he was three days and three nights
in the heart of the Earth
no the only reason people try to move
the crucifixion to a Wednesday is they
misunderstand Matthew chapter 12 where
Jesus said as Jonah was three days and
three nights in the heart of the earth
so the son of man will be or rather
Jonah three days three nights in the
belly of the fish
so the son of man will be three days
three nights in the heart of the Earth
the three days of Jesus begins with his
suffering and his surrender in the
Garden of Gethsemane So it's talking
about Thursday night Friday night
Saturday night he was suffering for the
sins of the world that's including the
suffering the death and the tomb he rose
Sunday morning so you don't need to move
the crucifixion to Wednesday by the way
we do have a book that talks about that
three days and three nights and it's
called the sign of Jonah that's right if
you'd like to receive the book just call
800-835-6747 one more where in the Bible
does it say God helps those who help
themselves
doesn't say that in the Bible that was
Benjamin Franklin hey listening friends
we're going to learn more next week tune
in tell your friends and go to
amazingfacts.org God bless
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]